civilizations have used the colors black
and white in their stories to represent
good and evil throughout human history
the Bible tells us black is evil and
white is good on the first page in the
beginning there was only darkness and
then God said let there be light and he
saw that the light was good cultures
across the world associate black with
evil death in the devil and to white
with purity of life and heaven so it's
no surprise that a black cat means bad
luck and angels wear white
since film began in black and white the
medium worked well for black and white
dualism with such a strong cultural
foundation filmmakers could easily give
cues about a character based on their
blackness or whiteness do you think
[ __ ] de passe abyssal into Sun the
appeal of black and white symbolism is
that it's easy to grasp the distinction
between two extremes with this binary
there's literally no gray area starting
with the Great Train Robbery Western
films and serials used to this
simplicity to their advantage black and
white hats are an easy way to tell who's
the good guy and who's the bad guy and
this tradition continues in modern
filmmaking where it seems like every
major franchise has incorporated the
symbolism in some way in the same way
that black and white symbolism creates a
simpler and clearer metaphor black and
white filmmaking creates a simpler and
clearer image I believe that black and
white is often actually preferable to
color especially in movies where
movement and timing and atmosphere are
more important than pretty pictures or
landscapes color can add too much
information to a scene the simplicity of
black and white filmmaking and black and
white imagery makes it an enticing tool
for filmmakers even while shooting in
color
despite the opportunity to use color
modern directors like David Fincher and
Christopher Nolan often choose
desaturated palettes that look almost
black and white this choice adds a
visual clarity to their scenes by
creating a simpler image desaturation is
a trend that extends beyond just Fincher
and Nolan it seems like whenever a
filmmaker wants to convey realism
normality or a sense of familiarity they
choose a less colorful palette many
critics defend black and white
filmmaking a superior pure cinema in
fact I think parents almost ought to
take kids and say hey look this is
another way that movies used to be made
in it's part of your cultural heritage
idea but whose cultural heritage is he
talking about The Birth of a Nation very
clearly exposes the racial undertones
see ated with black-and-white symbolism
in this film a white actor uses
blackface to show he's supposedly evil
and did the KKK dress in white to show
they are supposedly the heroes not only
was this film a massive commercial
success and a huge influence on modern
cinema but it also was partially
responsible for the rebirth of the Ku
Klux Klan the use of black and white
symbolism implies a racial binary with
whiteness being inherently good and
blackness being inherently evil but many
filmmakers challenge that binary in two
important ways first by flipping the
associations of black and white and
second by injecting that familiar binary
with something else entirely so when
does black and white not feel familiar
the classic interpretation of black and
white symbolism makes those colors feel
natural but sometimes filmmakers
exaggerate the colors to the point that
they no longer have that classic
association with good evil such a strong
contrast then feels uncomfortable to the
eye overdoing black and white to the
point of unease has a long history in
literature in Moby Dick
Ishmael feels intimidated by the colour
of the whale saying it was the whiteness
of the whale that above all things
appalled me for Melville there's an
apparent terror to the uniformity of
pure white objects that are purely black
and white are simple to a fault and feel
a little suspicious after all how can
something natural be that lacking of
color Moby Dick is an early example of
challenging whether something white is
automatically good and some movies use
completely white things in the exact
same way
rabbits they're supposed to be cute on
paper they're adorable lovable animals
have you ever gotten close to a rabbit
you can tell in their eyes they have the
brain of like a sociopath put a rabbit
brain and a human body you have Michael
Myers the killer in American Psycho the
set designer purposefully made Batemans
apartment too white to make it uneasy to
the eye when the realtor repaints Paul
Allen's apartments are completely white
the color feels nauseating don't make
any trouble please
I suggest you go
in the same way that these films
challenge black and white symbolism
other films shot in color challenged the
supposed familiarity of black and white
images the first and most famous example
is the Wizard of Oz where Dorothy
escapes the dull world of Kansas and
falls into the colorful Oz even such an
early color film portray black and white
as a place that a character might not
feel comfortable in Dorothy escapes the
restrictions of black and white in favor
of the colorful world of possibilities
in Oz but the film makes sure not to go
too far with the metaphor because in the
end
Dorothy happily returns home to her
familiar black and white life but the
satire Pleasantville used the same
metaphor to full effect the film follows
a brother and sister who get trapped in
a 1950s sitcom called Pleasantville the
fictional show echoes other popular
sitcoms at the time that starred a
typical American family and the town is
ordinary to a fault it has no toilets in
never rains and everybody always follows
the rules the creeps as the brother and
sister teach the town to break their
old-fashioned moral codes the town
slowly gains color in response the mayor
outlaws it he literally bans colored
people from entering certain
establishments this film shows how black
and white can feel to normal so put
together that it feels unnatural it also
shows how black and white represents a
traditional past specifically a past
that excluded colorful thinking and
literally colorful people it's a
question of whether we want to hold on
to those values that made this place
great
another unsettling part of Pleasantville
is the lack of color in its casting the
fact that there's no non-white residents
adds to the homogeneity of the town and
the residents within it we see the same
creepy homogeneity throughout American
Psycho where characters have identical
business cards aside from a slightly
different shade of white that's love way
coloring Patrick Bateman obsesses over
white because he wants to conform not
because he cares about purity innocence
or the idea of being good don't quit
because I want to fit in but the
obsession with fitting perfectly into
this molds brings bateman no
satisfaction in his case white
represents bateman's derangement and
obsession with power as a result of his
hyper masculine white elite environment
mid Samar a film shot almost entirely in
the middle of the day also disrupts
classic notions of light and whiteness
when the movie first came out critics
praised it as a daylight horror film
that subvert Adha tropes by dispelling
the idea that darkness is the only way
to create an unsettling tone in fact the
movie scrum events feel more disturbing
because they play out in broad daylight
with all the characters wearing white
all but one main character suffers a
violent end at the hands of a white
nordic tribe that wears mostly all-white
worships light and holds an annual
ritual to ward off the black one despite
the fact that the film intentionally
flips the horror genre on its head they
kept one glaring horror trope the black
guy dies first it's an oversight that
comes as a surprise in such an otherwise
subversive film and it plays into racial
tropes about black characters being more
expendable but his death also plays into
the cruelty of the white characters so
the trope simultaneously reinforces
daily black stereotypes and questions
existing white stereotypes
ultimately when filmmakers disrupt
classic notions of black and white they
create new possibilities around to
exactly the hero and the villain of the
story can be HBO's Watchmen employs
subversive black and white symbolism to
critique our concept of heroism the main
character Angela a bar sports an
all-black outfit at first it's unclear
whether she's a villain or a hero she
plays a cop that fights crime as part of
a questionably good police force full of
superheroes which she quickly finds out
is run by the KKK and her own
crime-fighting grandfather was himself
inspired by the black Western hero bass
Reeves who has an all-black outfit down
to the black hat perhaps the most
impactful use of black and white in
Watchmen is the episode this
extraordinary being in which Angela
relives the memories of her grandfather
the entire episode is shot in black and
white and similarly to Pleasantville
this episode denotes a serious shift in
tone rather than a gleeful and familiar
nod to the good old days this shift to
an entirely black and white palette is
accompanied by intense music and a
horrific series of violent racial events
this episode serves as a modern
retelling of the birth of a nation
hooded justice adopts his costume after
being lynched with Abel
bag and noose around his head fashions
it into a cape and becomes a dark
figured hero that fights off KKK members
in white hoods what if justice takes the
racial binary and literally fashions it
into something new
Watchmen perfectly captures an inversion
of black and white symbolism and imagery
to disrupt and question the status quo
so many filmmakers challenged the binary
of black and white by using those colors
in non-traditional ways to contradict
their association with good and evil but
films also have another way to challenge
the binary of black and white color of
course colors have many different
meanings themselves but when used in
direct contrast to a black and white
binary color can alarm challenge and
disrupt an image venture does prefer a
monochromatic image but it actually does
use color strategically to give visual
cues in seven the only character wearing
striking colors is John Doe his red
jumpsuit stands out in scenes otherwise
dominated by dark and earthy tones his
colorful outfit creates tension in a
world that previously had very little
color we immediately recognized him as
an outsider giving his scenes a sense of
unease that would not have been present
had he fit the overall color scheme and
in The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo the
colorful tools in the background to
create an ominous atmosphere because the
neon orange catches our eye and we
realize what those tools are for venture
mostly uses neutral tones to create a
pleasant image that laws the viewer into
a sense of normalcy when he occasionally
disrupts that normalcy with color the
effect alerts the viewer of characters
that threaten the visual status quo
Fincher plays on our comfort and
familiarity with black and white imagery
to create visual drama and fear within
his scenes it's so effective because
color has often been used to represent
the foreign and the alien Dorothy's
world is quite literally disrupted by
color in the form of the Land of Oz
colors association with foreign or even
alien landscapes is a common trope
compare Marvel films set on earth to the
one set in space filmmakers understand
that color is often associated with
something unfamiliar annihilation takes
us unfamiliarity to the extreme in this
film color is not just unfamiliar it's
terrifying the central antagonism in the
film is represented visually by intense
color the landscapes within the shimmer
are lit by an unnatural rainbow
refraction and it actually mutates by
making things
possibly color malignant tumors with
this disruption going down to the
molecular level contrast the shimmer
with the scenes outside of it and they
look just like Fincher's films mostly
grays and whites the shimmer works as an
antagonism because it plays on our
discomfort with color it represents an
alien change that makes us uneasy the
film depicts the foreboding infection of
color into an otherwise color of this
world these films reinforce the idea
that black and white is natural and
comfortable color only disrupts the
image in some way you and me tofu we
don't do lollipops and rainbows cuz we
know those are pretty colors they just
hide what the world oh really is black
and white but doesn't that cell color
short many black filmmakers embrace
color in their films and reject the
tradition of black and white early
cinema developed lighting techniques for
white faces within black and white color
schemes but those white centric
techniques were developed at the expense
of darker skin tones when comparing the
lighting of black faces in black and
white films with modern films like
moonlight and black Klansmen it's clear
that color lights black faces better
some also reject black and white for
symbolic reasons for some black and
white films represented time they were
excluded or marginalized which explains
why many black filmmakers actually use
more color to denote events in the past
sorry to bother you perfectly summarizes
what black and white movies can't do
it's a complete reversal of movies like
The Birth of a Nation instead of a white
people pretending to be black it's about
black people pretending to be white and
it reverses the idea that color feels
uncomfortable and black and white feels
natural you know 35 percent of men who
wear pink are more likely to start a
franchise as Cassius gains wealth and
status he moves to an apartment that
looks exactly like Patrick Bateman's
completely lacking in color but there is
one colorful item that stands out the
photo of his father which changes as he
sells out showing his father's
disapproval of the desaturated life
Cassius has chosen for himself it's one
thing to take the promotion but now you
are a full-on scab in this film color
represents authenticity and staying true
to your identity it makes sense that
black filmmakers have an affinity for
color both aesthetically and
thematically black and white symbolism
and film have their place at the movies
and black and white does create
beautiful images but it has its
limitations not only does this paradigm
simplify our thinking and literally
simplify the film image but that
simplification has historically been at
the expense of people not a part of the
status quo but with colorful filmmaking
it's not so easy to villainize some and
to worship others so I am grateful for
film shot in color because in the end
it's not also black and white color is
an excellent visual tool to illustrate
the complexities depth and humanity of
life films like annihilation do this
marvelously by using color to
demonstrate that nature is not only
enchantingly beautiful but also
dangerously complex and full of patterns
it's no wonder that nature documentaries
like planet Earth and Blue Planet are
shot in high-definition with saturated
colors the documentary nature's
mathematics actually explores the core
ideas that annihilation is based on by
using mathematics to understand nature's
inherent patterns and with curiosity
streams newly expanded library you can
watch nature's mathematics and thousands
of other documentary titles that use
vibrant color to understand nature's
mysteries curiosity stream is a
subscription-based video service with
big-budget nonfiction films but they've
also partnered with nebula a creator own
streaming service that's built by
content creators just like me
Nebula subscriptions are automatically
included with an annual subscription to
curiosity stream so you get the best of
both worlds
you can gain access to high-quality
documentary films while still supporting
independent creatives who rely on your
support to continue producing amazing
work plus you gain access to an extra
now you see it video ad free nebula also
features some awesome videos for my
fellow content creators one of my
favorites is how to music which teaches
you the sound production process behind
some of music's most iconic bands and
artists if you want to try both
curiosity stream and nebula go to
curiosity stream comm /nya si and enter
the promo code NY si when prompted
during the signup process
thanks to curiosity stream for
sponsoring and thanks to you our patrons
for your support if you want to support
our work directly join our patreon
thanks for watching
you